aber ich glaube tatsächlich wir haben
ein zunehmendes problem mit der
linksaußen agenda unserer bund
bundesinnenminister in nancy faeser also
erst ist sie aufgefallen mit
irgendwelchen fragwürdigen äußerungen
zur demonstrationsfreiheit oder zum
messenger diensten dann kam raus dass
sie für ein magazin einer wirklich
linksextremen organisation publiziert
hatte und statt dann zu sagen okay leute
ich habe das vielleicht falsch
eingeschätzt ich würde das nicht mehr so
machen und linksextremismus ist neben
rechtsextremismus und islamismus und
religiösem extremismus ein problem das
wir bekämpfen müssen statt deswegen hat
stattdessen hat sie wieder nur von
rechtsextremismus geredet und so getan
als gäbe es da kein problem dann hat sie
eine flüchtlingspolitik vorgeschlagen
die in ihrer eigenen behörde von den
sicherheitsbehörden als gefährlich
erachtet werden wurden das kann dann
raus weil sie eben illegale migration
befördern würde und den schlepperbanden
das leben leichter machen würde und so
kann man keine gute innenministerin sein
als innenministerin ist man zuständig
dafür unsere freiheitlich demokratische
grundordnung zu schützen und dann muss
man über jeden zweifel erhaben sein frau
fischer scheint auf dem linken auge
blind zu sein und so jemand kann nicht
innenministerin sein soja und kann die
verfassung verfassung schützen zu dieser
einsicht muss ich selber sehr sehr
schnell kommen und ansonsten muss auch
olaf scholz handeln denn das geht
einfach nicht an der spitze dieses
wichtige ministeriums na ja wo sich
zugegeben bei fräsern noch schlimmer
dass ihr demonstration eigentlich
verbieten wollte oder auch nicht mehr
den sinn bei demonstrationen zu sehen
schienen die mit krone zu haben was ich
ganz klar sagen muss ist das ist jetzt
etwas salopp formuliert aber der
linksextremismus hat eine bessere lobby
als der rechtsextremismus eigentlich
sind alle formen von extremismus falsch
und wir wollen sie als gesellschaftlich
aber ich finde linksextremismus hier
wirkt ja immer noch so eigentlich die
nehmen die leute noch so hin und ich
glaube das ist ganz ganz wichtig ist es
ja auch eine ganz scharfe abgrenzung zum
linksextremismus brauchen und das ist
mir manchmal ist es bei mir finde ich
einen gesellschaftlichen diskurs nicht
der fall unbedingt und ich habe ja diese
formulierung kampf gegen rechts schon
angesprochen es ist ja gar keine frage
wir müssen rechtsextremismus bis aufs
messer bekämpft so das ist eine riesige
gefahr das ist auch zu nehmen hat
todesopfer auch in der eigenen partei
wurden landrat der cdu ja auch chancen
von rechtsextremen also das geht einem
selber auch mal muss man sein will
braucht man uns überhaupt nichts
belehren dass wir das massiv bekämpfen
müssen genauso wie religiösen
extremismus aber auch linksextremismus
denn es steckt ja auch wieder andere
extremisten wenn wenn das wenn der staat
hat sich stabilisiert wird und die leute
sehen da wird mit zweierlei maß gemessen
das ist ein riesenproblem auch bei den
grünen übrigens dass da oft das auge
zugedrückt wird auch bei
vorfeldorganisationen von denen
vielleicht kommen wir da auch noch
darauf zu sprechen und deswegen wir
brauchen eine klare kante und wenn
gerade die innenministerin darum spur
bild auf dem linken auge blind ist und
nicht klare kante zeigt dann kriegen wir
dann probleme und das wird sich auch auf
andere bereiche ausweiten deswegen da
muss man handeln da kann man nicht
einfach aussitzen und da ist im zweifel
auch der kanzler gefragt aber ich habe
ja vor allen dingen gestaunt sie ist die
verfassungs ministerin und sie ist
glaube ich auch juristin wenn ich es
richtig weiß und sie haben es
angesprochen dieser dieser erste tweet
der skin sinngemäß für hass und hetze
gibt es die polizei und hass und hetze
sind gar keine straftat ist tatbestände
also da kommt noch nicht die polizei man
darf in diesem land hessen ist nicht
schön aber darauf mann und hetze gab es
ein straftatbestand in der ddr das war
staatsfeindliche hetze und boykott hetze
das kann man verfolgen mit dem
strafrecht aber mich hat einfach
gewundert dass sie in dieser
juristischen materie nicht fit ist und
dann sich zu einer meiner
gefühlswallungen hingibt und die aber so
rausposaunt das schon sehr seltsam und
die polizei kommt gleich gar nicht
allenfalls der staatsanwalt also das
seltsam ich fand es vor allen dingen
sehr schwierig also dass tatsächlich
innenminister in der bundesrepublik
deutschland die versammlungsfreiheit ja
ja eigentlich erst dann schaffst das hat
mich sehr erschüttert aber muss man sich
mal ein bisschen dann auch wieder noch
zurück in die zeit der großen koalition
gucken also ich glaube warum wir beim
rechtsextremismus so empfindlich sind in
deutschland ist klar das ist einfach
auch historische gegründet und das ist
auch zurecht irgendwie also in unserer
dna dass das das ist völlig in ordnung
so aber das auf der anderen seite nicht
ordentlich hingucken ist natürlich nicht
in ordnung und es gab ja aber auch die
ganze zeit unter kanzlerin merkel also
dieses programm demokratie leben das im
familienministerium angesiedelt war dass
es ständig aufwächst ich weiß jetzt
nicht die aktuelle zahl aber waren schon
zuletzt glaube ich so 130 millionen euro
im jahr und da hat ja die die cdu
damalige familien müssten kristina
schröder mal sehr tapfer versucht zu
sagen wir wollen eigentlich gerne
bekennt ist also einfach von allen die
da was kriegen da sind die
verschiedensten initiativen ist aber
sehr stark linkslastig das muss man
wirklich sagen und zwar zum teil auch
linkslastig mit abgrenzungsproblemen in
denen doch es also radikalen rand würde
ich mal sagen und da hat sie ja versucht
also die darauf festzulegen dass sie
sich doch bitte zur freiheitlich
demokratischen grundordnung bekennen
wenn sie also mittel aus diesem programm
beziehen wollen was ich jetzt nicht so
eine schreckliche zumutung fände er
nicht gesagt und das wurde ihr ja dann
also sozusagen sehr angekreidet und als
reaktionär naiv und dumm und ich kann
mich nicht so richtig doll erinnern dass
es in frau merkel frau schröder so
richtig verteidigt hätte damals bei die
cdu ja erst das 1 geführt hat dass man
eben diese klausel unterschreiben muss
wenn man öffentliche gelder bekannt dass
man sich zum grundgesetz bekennt aber
das war für uns enttäuschend aus meiner
sicht die beste familienministerin der
letzten zeiten aber sie hat das auf
jeden fall sehr gut gemacht aber das war
ja eine dafür also wir waren in einer
koalition mit der spd und das war ganz
klar die spd forderung die wollen das
ganz abschaffen und wir haben dann
zumindest noch in diese förderbescheide
reingeschrieben so um die gewissen
abschreckungseffekte zu erzielen aber
das brauche ich nicht unbedingt und das
ganze wiederum hat schlagseite auch die
bundeszentrale für politische bildung da
sind ja auch parteien und über
ministerien und so weiter ist man da
vertreten im kuratorium und so weiter
das ist da vorkommnisse gab wo man sagt
dieses wichtige neutrale diese instanz
ist mit fragwürdigen artikeln äußerungen
unterwegs das geht einfach nicht und
dann müssen auch parteien da muss auch
die cdu dann mehr machen wenn sie die
möglichkeit also ich stimme dem zu
gebrauchen eine ganz klare abgrenzung
nach rechts aber auch eine klare
abgrenzung nach links und ich muss sagen
als unternehmerin ich beobachte dass er
alles mich nerven ja diese ganzen links
rechts kämpfen die wir haben und von
einer innenministerin wie der liebe
nancy wünscht mir einig dass sie sich
ihren job macht das heißt sie ist
eigentlich dafür verantwortlich dass die
kluge einwanderungspolitik macht keine
an wanderung in unsere sozialsysteme
sondern wirklich danach schaut dass wir
hier nach deutschen auch fachkräfte
bekommen weil das es mit eines der
größten sorgen die wir als unternehmer
momentan haben und darüber sollten wir
diskutieren über ihr aufgabengebiet und
diese aufgabe die sie hat weil wie
gesagt das ganze thema links rechts wir
brauchen die abgrenzung rechts ist
genauso schlimm wie links und das sollte
eigentlich klar sein und dann sollte
jetzt wie gerade eine innenministerin
sollte ihren job machen bin ich der
meinung gerade in der migrationspolitik
ist allerdings das programm der ampel
auch sehr schwierig also das muss man
schon sagen da wird einerseits
der sogenannte spurwechsel versucht das
heißt ich kann mich zunächst auf meinen
asylstatus berufen wenn der nicht klappt
dann kann ich einen job annehmen und
dann kann ich als arbeitsmigranten
probieren wir haben in den letzten
jahren gesehen das obwohl mehr als zwei
millionen menschen gekommen sind die
fachkraft lücke gewachsen ist das heißt
es sind nicht die gekommen die die lücke
schließen und wir haben etwa eine
million hartz 4 bezieher mit
ausländischen pass die meisten in den
schutzstatus also sollen eigentlich
wieder zurück dürfen auch nicht arbeiten
das andere was die ampel jetzt
einrichten möchte ist dass es reicht per
eidesstattlicher erklärung seine
personalien anzugeben also all das mit
den weggeworfenen papieren was wir
bislang hatten das wird dann quasi
legalisiert und
das schafft mit migrations anreize in
der mitte europas und betrifft natürlich
alle umliegenden länder auch die
plötzlich zu transitländern werden und
es erhöht den druck an den europäischen
außengrenzen also europa ist nicht
nur an den sonntags projekt sondern die
gerade die deutschen müssten sich dann
aber auch abstimmen mit den anderen
ländern ob die das eigentlich auch alle
wollen denn wenn menschen nach europa
kommen sind sie im schengen raum aber
deswegen sage ich ja kluge
einwanderungspolitik am besten mit einem
punktesystem aller kanada wir brauchen
einwanderung von fachkräften und da
sollte man auch wirklich drauf schauen
wie gesagt keine einwanderung in unsere
sozialsysteme und das erwarte ich auch
von einer innenministerin dass sie so
ein programm oder grundsätzlich
regierung auch aufsetzt
schwinge ich bin
ich zu den leuten die traditionell immer
noch ein bisschen hoffnung hatten dass
man tatsächlich eine form von
einwanderungsgesetz hinbekommen kann das
richtige anreize setzt und das dann
tatsächlich menschen die gerne hier
arbeiten wollen und die unserem
arbeitsmarkt was zu bieten haben dass
die gerne kommen können vielleicht auch
etwas leichter als das bisher der fall
ist denn das ist ja dann wieder
bürokratisch sogar also für eu nicht
ganz unaufwendig und dass wir
qualifizierte jüngere menschen bräuchten
ich meine das schreit einen ja praktisch
von jedem lieferwagen aus jedem
schaufenster bei jedem wetter überall
hängen zettel mitarbeitern gesucht und
das ist ja sozusagen qualifizierte jobs
auch der fall also dass wir irgendwie
bedarf haben und dass wir durch unsere
eigene demographie nicht mehr decken
weil wir alle also in meinem alter zu
wenig genau zu sagen dass das ist ja so
insofern also intelligente einwanderung
wäre natürlich tatsächlich auch
eigentlich was schön ist also eigentlich
was also diese dieses lege eine
fortschritts kollidieren sein warum
nicht mal also sozusagen schöne sagt
attraktive angebote sowohl für menschen
die hier leben als auch für menschen die
hierher kommen wollen aber dann muss man
eben klar definieren fast dann die
fragen ist
ja und ich glaube also ich glaube das
ist auch deswegen nicht passiert weil es
daher eine ideologie gibt die dahinter
steht also diese open borders ideologie
ist ja tatsächlich das sagen viele bei
spd und grünen das ist im grunde gar
keine grenzen mehr geben sollte und dass
migration über grenzen hinweg ungeregelt
einfach stattfinden können sollte das
ist gerade von der basis her gibt es da
viel druck von der grünen jugend und so
weiter und das ist natürlich eine ganz
gefährliche ideologie weil wir damit
auch da sind wir wieder beim punkt
vertrauen die menschen merken natürlich
dass das nicht funktionieren kann es ist
im grunde genommen auch ein stück von
stückweit gnadenlos wenn man auch leuten
damit hoffnungen macht die sich auf den
weg machen und sich damit in große
gefahr begibt und dass das kann nicht
funktionieren aber das ist eben das
problem das dahintersteht glauben sich
bei spd und grünen ich werde mich sehr
unfair sein aber ich bin es jetzt
natürlich doch und erinnerte aber auch
noch einmal an den satz wir schaffen das
zum thema integration der natürlich sind
sagen viele menschen auch sehr verstört
hat das war nämlich diejenigen die das
schaffen mussten in ihrer schule auf
ihrem schulhof wo ihre kinder
drangsaliert werden wenn sie ein
butterbrot im ramadan essen und was weiß
ich was alles wenn ich also die
kanzlerin hat das sehr
menschenfreundlich und oben hin gesagt
und sozusagen aber konkret und sehr
wenig angeboten wie der integration die
dann eben auch robust ist und die
menschen etwas abverlangt konkret
aussehen sollte und das mussten
irgendwie andere leute regeln und wie
schlecht das total funktioniert kann man
sich in den quartieren die davon die
damit viel zu tun haben sehr lebendig
ansehen und nicht insofern es ist es
kann ihre kritik an an traf esa da jetzt
absolut nachvollziehen nur gerade weil
bei der einwanderungs thematik hat
glaube ich frau merkel uns da auch eine
hypothek einem vertrauensverlust
hypothek hinterlassen also dass wir bei
der integration auch noch große
herausforderung haben ist klar in
hamburg ich war letztens bei so einer
israel mahnwache in der hamburger
innenstadt wie war auch wurde mal
angegriffen antisemitisch und dann sind
wir da hingegangen solidarität gezeigt
wenn sie da stehen denn der hamburger
innenstadt nur neben der israel fahne
kommt alle fünf minuten jemand vorbei
und macht irgendwie blöde bemerkungen
beschimpft ein komisch an bedroht mit
körperlichen gesten das habe ich in
meinem alter nie so erlebt das muss man
wirklich so machen und das ist immer so
dass das das sozusagen aus einer ecke
kommt und dass man sieht das ist es dann
auch integrationsprobleme und das ist
ich bin da völlig d'accord soweit gehört
aber auch nach 2015 war es auch die
union die die einwanderung die illegale
einwanderung massiv reduziert hat und
die zahlen unter das niveau was es
vorher war wieder zurückbringen konnte